[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 20 décembre voici le
programme de ce soir un nouveau moyen de
transport innovant arrive bientôt à
l'île de loisirs de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline pour les Jeux Olympiques de
Paris 2024 il sera entièrement autonome
et piloté par une intelligence
artificielle l'utilisateur n'ura qu'à
appuyé sur un bouton pour arriver à
destination la Croix Rouge s'entraîne à
vous sauver mouvement de foule ou
explosion de gaz les secouristes se
forment aux pires situations ils étaient
250 bénévoles au Mureau dimanche dernier
pour savoir comment intervenir durant
les catastrophes connaissez-vous le
principe du Park il s'agit d'un espace
où votre chien peut se dépenser en toute
liberté et sécurité dans les ivelines la
ville de carrière soupoissi détient le
plus grand caniparc de la région nous
sommes partis à sa découverte et enfin
en deème partie d'émission l'invité du
78 ce soir nous parlerons de rugby avec
le club de Versailles l'équipe connaît
un début de saison mitigé voilà pour le
programme de ce soir mais tout de suite
on va prendre la direction de l'île de
loisirs de Saint-Quentin en Eveline au
printemps un nouveau moyen de transport
pour les Jeux Olympiques de Paris 2024
sera expérimenté auprès du grand public
son nom l'Urban loop il s'agit de
capsules qui se déplacent toute seule
sur des rails l'objectif créer un
circuit de 2 km entre un site
d'hébergement et la future Fan Zone le
ministre des Transports Clément bon
était présent hier matin pour
officialiser le début du chantier
1 2 3
ça va l'urbane looupe est sur la bonne
voie ce mardi 19 décembre le ministre
des Transports Clément baonne était à
l'île de loisirs de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline présentation du véhicule et
pause du premier rail un moment
symbolique pour annoncer
l'expérimentation de ce nouveau moyen de
transport pour les Jeux Olympique 2024
un circuit de 2 km desservant le grand
parking lieu de la future Fan Zone et un
site d'hébergement au niveau du Relais
Des canardtière c'est une très belle
innovation pour les transports et pour
les mobilités c'est innovation qui est
électrique c'est innovation française
qui associe l'Université des
entrepreneurs des élus et Saint-Quentin
a été justement au rendez-vous dès le
départ maintenant nous sommes prêts et
c'est important d'être à l'heure des
Jeux Olympiques parce que c'est le
moment où on va pouvoir avoir assez de
voyageurs pour expérimenter ce qui est
aujourd'hui une mobilité totalement
innovante et encore une fois décarboné
donc qui participe à ces grands
objectifs qu'on se fixe de sobriété
alimenté par un courant de très basse
tension dans les rails les 10 futures
capsules seront autonomes et piloté par
des algorithmes d'intelligence
artificielle elles pourront accueillir
chacune deux passagers un trajet
écologique à 50 km/h à moins d'un
centime d'euros le kilomètre curban loop
c'est un système de transport qui est
dédié aux zones de moyenne densité c'est
par le centrreville de Paris par le
centreville de Marseille mais des villes
comme saint-ctin niveline où on souhaite
être plus rapide que la voiture on ne
fait pas d'attentequé il y a toujours
des véhicules qui viennent se rechargé
comme des télécabines sur les dans les
stations on arrive on rentre on appuie
sur la station ou sur laquelle on
souhaite aller les portes se ferment et
après le véhicule va directement à sa
destination sans s'arrêter débuté en
septembre 2023 les travaux se
poursuivront jusqu'à la mi-janvier avec
la pose des derniers rails les navettes
hyperlop seront testées à vide dès
février avec une ouverture au public à
la fin du printemps cette
expérimentation de 17 mois d'un coûpt de
5 millions d'euros est financé à hauteur
de 800000 € par l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin en
Yveline allez c'est l'heure à présent de
faire le point sur les informations à
retenir aujourd'hui dans les
Yvelines et c'est avec vous Michel
midoro bonsoir bonsoir on commence avec
C information ce matin le château de
Versailles a une nouvelle fois été
évacué pour des raisons de sécurité
effectivement Mathilde y s géré d'une
nouvelle alerte à la bombe qui a
entraîné l'évacuation de près de 2000
visiteurs à 10h20 le château a pu
rouvrir en début d'après-midi depuis
quelques mois le monument est visé par
ce type d'alerte pour rappel au mois
d'octobre SEP fausses alertes ont eu
lieu en seulement 8 jours on va parler
de politique à présent et notamment de
la loi immigration la loi immigration a
été adoptée hier ce texte prévoit
d'instaurer des quotas migratoires et
des cartes de séjour délivré
automatiquement pour les métiers en
tension tels que le secteur du bâtiment
et de l'aide à domicile les négociations
autour de cette loi ont été agitées dans
les ibines tous les députés de la
majorité ont approuvé ce texte sauf
nadiae elle estime que la proposition
finale de la loi est trop ferme et trop
peu sensible aux problématiques vécues
par les personnes étrangères et la
plateforme parcours sup à ouvert ce midi
oui mais attention les choix
d'orientation se feront seulement à part
partir du 17 janvier pour l'instant
seule la consultation des 23000
formations est possible les élèves de
terminale et pour la première fois ceux
de seconde peuvent profiter des
nouveautés que le site propose la
version 2024 permet notamment de
comparer les formations automatiquement
vous retrouverez également sur le site
les dates des prochaines portes ouvertes
qui vous intéressent et enfin on termine
ces informations par une innovation
unique en France une innovation unique
en France qui permettra peut-être une 5
g plus performante dans les ivelines le
Laboratoire national de métrologie et
DCL LNE situé à traape a décidé de
collaborer avec Nexio une entreprise
spécialisée dans
l'électromagnétisme ce partenariat a
donné naissance au laboratoire
radiofréquen mais alors qu'est-ce que
c'est il s'agit d'un laboratoire qui
permettra d'avoir une communication plus
rapide et à terme d'avoir la 6G Mathilde
plusieurs secteurs sont concernés don
l'industrie le médical le transport
ferroviaire aéronautique et l'automobile
bien merci beaucoup michelel midoro pour
toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
image ou une information qui vous a
marqué prè près de chez vous n'hésitez
pas à nous la partager sur les réseaux
sociaux en utilisant le hashtag 78
news comment prendre en charge les
victimes d'une explosion de gaz ou d'un
mouvement de foule dimanche dernier la
Croix-Rouge organisait une journée de
formation à grand échelle dans la ville
des Mureaux l'objectif pour les
secouristes répondre à la prise en
charge du nombre important de victimes
Patrick Jacques de dixmud et Gabriel
Gontier se sont rendus sur
place simuler la prise en charge d'une
situation de crise à plusieurs victimes
le temps d'une journée une centaine de
membres des délégations territoriales de
la Croix-Rouge accompagné d'étudiants de
formation médicale se sont exercés à la
prise en charge de nombreuses victimes
la manœuvre a commencé depuis maintenant
un peu plus d'une heure où on avait deux
dispositifs de secours qu'on a
l'habitude de mettre en place sur
différentes manifestations et au cours
de ces dispositif de secours il y a eu
une situation notamment une simulation
d'une explosion et sur un autre
événement un mouvement de foule qui a
amené à avir une situation à de
nombreuses victimes donc là où on a dû
déployer de de des moyens
supplémentaires pour pour venir en aide
aux équipes déjà sur place l'objectif de
cet exercice au centre hospitalier
intercommunal Melan les Mureau
appréhender des situations d'urgence et
créer une cohésion entre les secouristes
des différentes délégations
départementales présentes à la formation
1 2
3 soumis à deux situations de crise au
même moment les secouristes sont formés
au soin simultané d'un grand nombre de
victimes dans les meilleures conditions
possiblesett sur la chaise d'accord voir
appelle ça vous emmenz voir un médecin
ok d'accord l'objectif c'est de réussir
à faire en sorte que le commandement
soit capable de prioriser en fonction
des moyens qu'il a à ses disposition au
moment où il prend des décisions et en
même temps de garantir que nos
secouristes sont capables d'effectuer
les gestes techniques sur le terrain au
moment où on a besoin d'eux à l'approche
des Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 ces
exercices n'ont pas été choisis au
hasard le but est aussi de préparer au
mieux la sécurité de l'événement qui
accueillera plus de 16 millions de
spectateurs se permettre de déplacer
madame un petit peu parce que pour
glisser le oui il va
falloir tango twist ou passo doblé le
thé dansant de plaisir permet aux
personnes âgées de trouver l'amour ou de
se faire des amis près d'une centaines
de danseurs viennent virevolter chaque
mois au rythme d'un orchestre musette un
moment de convivialité qui leur permet
de rompre la solitude c'est le reportage
de Julien
Leroi
une histoire d'amour en chanson
Jacqueline vient chaque mois dans ce thé
dansant de la commune de plaisir une
appétence pour la musique partagé avec
ses amis et une rencontre inattendue
célibataire durant 20 ans elle fait la
connaissance de Michel dans ce lieu en
2018 le début d'une relation complice
autour de la passion du tango je venais
danser depuis quelques années et un beau
jour mais je l'ai rencontré en dansant
il est venu m'inviter une fois deux
foisord puis et puis voilà puis on est
reparti ensemble on s'est tout de suite
entendu pour la danse hein bon et après
il y a eu un peu plus quoi et
voilà rendez-vous mensuel incontournable
pour les seiors de plaisir et de ses
alentours depuis mai 2017 ce thé dansant
est installé dans la salle des fêtes des
Gâtines passe au doblé Vals twist ou
rock quelques notes de musique pour
rompre la solitude un temps d'évasion
pour certains après l'interruption due à
la pandémie de covid-19
au départ nos seigneors étaient un petit
peu frileux bien évidemment ça peut se
se comprendre mais mais par la suite
nous avons vu une recrudesence de de
participation leur permet de sortir de
chez eux de voir du monde de discuter
avec d'autres personnes et de passer un
bon après-midi avec un goûter 16h lors
d'une pause bien mérité boisson et
pâtisserie pour reprendre des forces
entre 80 et 100 danseurs viennent à
chaque rang rende-v pour fouler la piste
un moment chaleureux de partage que ces
deux copines ne manquerai sous aucun
prétexte on fait plein de rencontres on
est avec nos amis et puis tout le monde
pleurait qu'il y avait pas de thé
dansant maintenant qu'on a un thé
dansant on participe alors moi je viens
surtout parce que j'aime beaucoup danser
on aime bien on retrouve pas mal de
copines et on discute bon on trouve
quelque fois des bons danseurs c'est
très agréable programmé chaque premier
jeudi du mois le thé dansant de plaisir
coûte 15 € par personne collation
comprise quelques pas échanger pour
mieux découvrir l'autre le temps d'une
chanson ou d'une vie
entière saviez-vous que dans les
ivelines nos compagnons à quatre pattes
possèd leur propre air de jeu saut
d'obstacle tunnel slalom les canyark
permettent aux chiens de se dépenser en
toute liberté et sécurité la ville de
carrière soupoissi détient le plus grand
caniparc de la région nous sommes partis
à sa
[Musique]
découverte bonjour je suis ATIS Baré
conseillère municipal à la ville de
poissie et aujourd'hui je vais vous
faire découvrir le plus grand cannyark
de la région donc nous sommes au
cannyark hashiko à carrière spoissi ou
hashiko pour ceux qui souhaitent aspirer
le ha
allons-y
alors et c'est parti
[Musique]
bonjour k bonjour Merci beaucoup nous
accueillir aujourd'hui au Canny Park à
Chico alors est-ce que tu peux nous
préciser comment est venu cette
impulsion cette volonté de créer ce can
parc à carrière sous poissi depuis 2020
la mairie a une politique volontariste
en faveur du bien-être animal et la
création du can park s'engage en fait
s'inscrit dans une politique un peu plus
large sur la de l'animal en ville sur la
place de l'animal domestique et l'animal
sauvage et c'est depuis 2021 avec une
consultation citoyenne que l'idée du
parc a un peu émergé on nous av demandé
au fait au crois leur avis pour savoir
si ils étaient intéressés s'il y avait
vraiment un besoin sur le territoire
d'un Kenny Park et c'est à suite de
cette consultation que le Cany Park et
et sa création grâce au Département a pu
être concrétisé sur la ville est-ce que
tu peux nous dire nous décrire un petit
peu en fait le Cany par avec ses agréés
je suppose qu'il y a il y a un règlement
une gestion en terme d'agré il y en a
cinq donc il y a des a des tunnels
rigides des balançoirs et aussi des des
saut d'obstacle de manière générale
permett d'avoir plusieurs types
d'activités qui sont disponible pour
pour les animaux et en terme de
règlement c'est un règlement qui est
assez simple les chiens doivent être
contrôlés par les maîtres les déjections
doivent être nettoyé aussi par les
maîtres également et c'est un un espace
qui est ouvert manière libre à chacun
avec un ou deux animaux de manière
générale au maximum par mètre et bien
merci beaucoup Kevin nous avoir reçu
merci
[Musique]
fraya
alors du coup est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire quels sont les avantages pour
vous pour votre chien du Canny Park au
niveau de sa santé au niveau de sa
cohésion sociale smog est un chien qui a
besoin de beaucoup d'activité en fait
donc vraiment bouger au moins 2 heur par
jour courir et là c'est un espace qui
est libre d'accès et il aime beaucoup
ces activités qui sont proposées tout à
fait gratuitement pour tout le monde
oui
[Musique]
donc le Canny Park fait partie de votre
parcours également est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire un petit peu les
bienfaits des Cany Park euh ce qui est
bien dans le Cany Park c'est que c'est
clôturé et il y a pas tous les chiens
qui restent toujours avec nous alors là
ils sont en sécurité ça rassure les gens
de pouvoir laisser leurs chiens
le point de rencontre pour les chiens et
même des chiens qui sont peureux ils
commencent à faire c'est très important
pour les chiens sont des animaux très
sociable et et c'est vrai que même pour
nous aussi on fait des rencontres on a
tous on a le même intérêts on échange
des informations des des astuces pour
les chiens pour la nourriture et c'est
très agréable et vous venez donc par
tous les temps même quand il fait un
froid de chien puisque vous prenez votre
café juste après toujours il y a
toujours la POS gourmande pour les
chiens et pour nous et c'est vrai que
quand il pleut quand tu es seul tu n'as
pas trop envie d'y aller mais vu que tu
sais qu'il y a du monde ici viens et tu
sais que le moment est là que quelqu'un
amène le chocolat chaud ou le café ou
l'impératif on vient voilà et ça motive
et c'est plus même s'il pleut on y va
parce que malheur partager c'est c'est
plus facile ouais voilà et bien allons-y
allons rejoindre la foule allez c'est
parti Sabine on va faire le goûter gros
[Musique]
alle alors comme vous pouvez le
constater en ville donc les canipark
sont des lieux de sécurité vous pouvez
promener votre chien c'est des lieux qui
permettent d'avoir de la cohésion
sociale pour vos animaux mais également
pour vous-même voilà à très
[Musique]
bientôt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il vous reste 4 jours pour finaliser vos
cadeaux de Noël pour vous aider la
rédaction de tv78 vous donne tous les
jours une idée 100 % yvelinoise si vous
nous suivez sur les réseaux sociaux vous
avez sans doute sans doute vu passer
notre calendrier de l'Avent je vous
propose qu'on ouvre ensemble la case
d'aujourd'hui envie de célébrer les
fêtes avec des ma locaux sur votre table
pour ce calendrier de l'avent de tv78 je
vous fais découvrir la truite de la
pisculture de
[Musique]
Villette au cœur de la vallée de la veau
couleur dans le nord des Yvelines cette
picyculture est installée depuis 1896
truite arc-en-ciel fario ou jaune sont
élevés sur place dans des bassins le
nourrissage est manuel et garanti sans
OGM pour des saveurs exalté préféré les
fumé au feu de bois compte 3 € pour une
truite fraîche de 250 g et 4,80 € pour
une truite fumée de 150 g alors pour
découvrir le goût authentique de ce
produit yvelinois haut de gamme
rendez-vous dans la boutique sur
place et c'est bientôt l'URE de l'invité
du 78 mais avant je vous propose qu'on
jette un coup d'œil à la météo de
[Musique]
demain demain matin le ciel sera bien
couvert sur l'ensemble des eline du côté
de mante la jolie attendez-vous aussi à
quelques averses au niveau des
températures il fera 8°gr à rambouillé
9°gr à oudans et Versailles et 11 à
Mantel jolie l'après-midi le ciel sera
toujours aussi couvert dans tout le
département nous devrions aussi avoir de
la pluie côté température il fera 11 à
13°gr en moyenne et demain nous fêterons
la Saint-Pierre canicius c'est l'heure à
présent de passer à l'invité du
et ce soir avec l'invité du 78 nous
allons parler de rugby et plus
particulièrement du Rugby Club de
Versailles Pierre Chevalier bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous êtes responsable de
la communication pour le club le début
de saison a été mitigé et mitigé il est
un peu compliqué le RC Versailles est
pour l'instant avant-dernier au
classement de la fédérale 2 l'année
dernière pourtant qu vous étiez vous
aviez de bons résultats comment est-ce
que vous expliquez cette différence
alors il y a pas mal de paramètres le le
premier c'est on va dire une une sorte
d'habitude dans le dans le sport et dans
le rugby quand on grimpe d'un niveau
comme c'est le cas de du RCV depuis
depuis deux saisons maintenant passage
de la Fédérale 3 à la fédéral 2 il y a
toujours une une une périodeadaptation
elle a été plutôt prolifique et plutôt
plutôt couronné de succès la première
année puisque sur notre première saison
historique en fédéral 2 les seiors se
sont qualifiés pour les phases finales
et cette deuxè saison et vous l'avez
vous l'avez rappelé compliqué sur cette
cette phase
allée plusieurs raisons à cela la
première c'est que nous avons perdu
quelques joueurs cadres de notre
effectif de l'an dernier notamment notre
capitaine notamment des joueurs de
première ligne d'expérience et qui qui
aussi avait cette ce basût et cette et
cet esprit qui qui lié le vestiaire euh
le recrutement le recrutement je pense
qu'on on en parlera un petit peu plus
tard il a il a été il a été ciblé mais
on ne remplace pas certaines
personnalités certaines individualités
dans un sport si collectif que le rugby
comme ça et si et si facilement ça met
du temps à se créer une équip on dit
souvent qu'il faut que la mayonnaise
prenne et que qu'un groupe justement
puisse apprendre à jouer et à gagné
ensemble on a eu également quelques
blessures assez sévères notamment chez
des recrues comme chez des comme chez
des joueurs qui étaiit déjà de de longue
date au club donc trois trois blessures
sévères au genou notamment dès le début
de saison et donc au fur et à mesure de
de ces phases de ces phases allées ben
le le je dirais le le la pièce qui ne
tombe pas du bon côté et puis un manque
de chance aussi parce qu'il en faut il
en faut aussi dans dans le sport
collectif et euh pas un manque de
motivation ou un manque de mental
également parce que durant les deux
derniers matchs vous avez perdu souvent
à un point d'écart 17 à 18 face à Amien
et 30 à 29 face à
oxer c'est un manque de motivation alors
pas pas de motivation ni même ni même de
ni même de mental c'est un c'est un un
problème de gestion de gestion du match
donc plutôt plutôt de de ne pas paniquer
quand quand l'adversa remonte au score
puisque sur les deux matchs que vous que
vous venez de rappeler euh le RCV menait
et donc s'est fait rejoindre rejoindre
et passer passer en toute fin en toute
fin de match notamment c'était le cas à
osser donc c'est c'est un problème de
euh là de de de gestion des émotions
peut-être plus que du mental à la fin et
de et de de pouvoir en gros mettre la
main sur le match et garder garder le
score quel que soit quel que soit le les
circonstances et queles que soient les
actions donc ça le club est en train de
travailler dessus exactement on va dire
qu'il il y a un nouveau Championnat qui
qui démarre avec avec avec ses phases
retour et puis quand même pas mal
d'espoir le le le club et le groupe
senior reste très serein c'estàdire que
il y a une situation où on a on a
rarement été dans ces dans ces méandres
du classement les saisons précédentes
mais il y a pas de panique il y a il y a
autant de sérénité que possible il y a
on va pas se cacher il y a urgence il a
urgence on a vu le classement s'afficher
à l'écran quelques minutes avant c'est
serré quand même entre la 11e et la 7e
place est-ce que vous avez encore
l'intention de revenir est-ce que c'est
encore possible de revenir alors on est
dans les on est finalement encore plus
dans les plaques de notre objectif de
début de saison qui était le maintien en
fédéral 2 c'est sur les premières
saisons de ne pas de de ne pas voir trop
haut et puis et puis de rester humble
dans notre dans notre façon de voir les
choses et d'aborder d'aborder les
saisons la première saison l'année
l'année dernière nous a permis quand
même de nous qualifier donc là là il y a
eu il y a eu un une sorte d'euphorie
postmée avec une avec une je dirais une
des performances qui ont continué à qui
ont continué à arriver après après la
montée cette année c'est Mo cas ça c'est
sûr et
donc c'est c'est remettre un petit peu
de l'ORD dans la maison mieux gérer nos
matchs quand on a par exemple sur un sur
un match comme de de samedi dernier on a
joué en nocturne contre Anthony 70 % de
de possession en 2uxè mi-temps et que ça
ça ne marque pas et ça ne veut pas
sourir on a quand même un groupe qui est
assez solide et qui ne qui ne qui ne
baisse pas les bras et qui est convaincu
que la la phase retour est une est un
nouveau championnat avec notamment une
une un bon élément c'est que vous l'avez
rappelé il y a il y a c'est très serré
dans la deuxème partie du championnat
donc pour ceux pour les les équipes qui
luttent à ne pas descendre et là on va
on va avoir ce mini championnat avec
quatre équipes et qu'on reçoit toutes à
la maison à porche fontaine ça va
changer les chosesel disons que ce sont
des circonstances qui nous qui nous qui
nous garantissent un petit peu plus de
positif dans la tête et dans l'envie
déjà de de pouvoir remettre le château
involet au rugby donc à vous entendre
vous croyez encore aux phase finale en
fait alors pH phase finale ça
maintien ça c'est donc se maintenir en
fédéral 2 parce que il y a un certain
nombre de de projets d'ambition qui qui
repos sur une présence de versaill en
fédéral
2 les phases finales après tout c'est
vrai qu'on on pourrait y penser là en
toute humilité le maintien et l'objectif
principal assumé et
confirmé ça pourrait basculer si on si
on faisait un ou deux coups à
l'extérieur par exemple dans le pendant
les phases retour et alors qu'est-ce
qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour l'année
2024 le maintien le maintien et euh et
puis euh et puis garder garder ce
plaisir et cétat d'esprit à jouer à
jouer ensemble euh et puis porter au
plus haut les couleurs bleu et blanches
dans cette saison de fédéral 2 et bien
merci beaucoup Pierre Chevalier d'avoir
répondu à nos questions en plateau
prochain match le dimanche 14 janvier à
domicile face à plousané on vous
souhaite de gagner et c'est la fin de
cette émission merci pour votre fidélité
je vous souhaite une belle soirée sur
tv78 prenez soin de
[Musique]
vous